because if i was a police officer that
came and i said what's the [ __ ]
and i've i've been following the case
yeah as soon as i see him how to see the
victims
it makes all the sense just get in the
back and we'll deal with this afterwards
i'm not going to deal with the cuffs
please just get in there just get in the
car paperwork's gonna be double what it
usually is
[Music]
guys girls it's time to stop complaining
yo mom's dad's children a lot of you
it's happening it's happening the time
has finally come
it's come guys drum roll please
our first live show ever sng live is
coming
you asked for it you got it you got it
man right guys so we've got numbers to
go through and things to go through so
we don't wanna listen yeah shut up shut
up let's listen let's get through it
because we'll forget right guys the show
is on the 23rd of june in the year 2022
2022 that's this year this year right
23rd of june 2022 at bush hall in london
yeah if you need to get on a plane book
your flight first
then get your ticket pattern that flow
yeah
get to london on the 23rd of june at
busch hall guys right yeah
10 a.m this thursday this thursday
that's thursday 26th of may that's this
thursday this thursday 26th of may this
thursday
patrons 10 a.m because we love you
you guys are gonna get early access
tickets that's easy first class access
first 10 years access 10 a.m get on it
at 10 am set your alarms
car if the ting flies off the shelf
flies off the shelves yeah don't message
me saying oh i tried to get on there but
they were it's not my business don't
look at me like i owe you anything
basically
basically
because i don't we've done our jobs
we've done our part guys so guys if
you're not on patreon yeah and you need
early access tickets because we might
sell out on patreon we might we don't
know it's a possibility so if you need
it
get on patreon just for that one day
yeah man this thursday 10 a.m 10 a.m
okay 26th of may don't forget it 26th of
may head on over to patreon make sure
you're a patreon get your
tickets bruv for our first live show
in london okay
now guys general admission general sale
tickets
friday we don't forget about you 27th of
may
10 a.m also 10 a.m or so you only got
like 24 hours if there are tickets left
by all means run it up
but if they're not
your business your business we've done
told you patreon mandem get the early
access patreon get first dibs if they
leave any scraps for you man you might
fight for that you're gonna fight
[Laughter]
fight for that fight for that so guys
one more time for the people at the back
okay
if you want to come and see us live sng
first live tour sng if you want to
experience some sip sips with your boys
if you want to chirps a thing on stage
on stage face to face lip to lip knows
to know stop
stop
if you want to run some jokes guys if
you want to meet and greet if you want
to hug your boys in person some people
like a hug
i'm not afraid i'm not afraid of that
there we go if you want to have some
story times if you want to go through am
i the arsehole's lives if you want the x
live guys
23rd of june bush hall london london
brav tickets go on sale for the patrons
this
thursday 26th of may 10
a.m general sale
at c tickets dot com
friday
27th of may
10 a.m see tickets dot com get your
tickets brav because we can't
do any favors there's nothing else we
can do we've done what we've had to do
we've listened to you guys and here are
here is the information we've given it
to you list by list by list yeah we're
gonna be there that's we're gonna that's
our only commitment we need to make is
that we're there and we're going to be
there so guys head on over get your
tickets once you've got your ticket then
you can message me yeah relax yeah you
can be like
message me all you want message for it
all you want once you've got your ticket
but if you haven't got it and you're
begging for it don't bother me because
we can't do anything about the ticket
sales yeah you can't do anything about
it once they've gone through so many
seats they're gone but guys thank you so
much we are super super super super
super excited to see you we are but it's
going to be a great time and it's going
to be the first day if you're over there
in south africa yeah australia finland
america and you're just like this is
some [ __ ] we will make our way make
our way world tour preferably make your
way over here first yeah first come come
through first yeah and it will branch
out later yeah of course but yeah if if
you if you're on a no-fly list and
you're vex that you can't come see us we
will eventually branch out yeah yeah
this is the first if you want to be the
that guy if you're a cloud chaser and
you say you're that kind of guy that's
like oh girl that's like
i saw them at the first team yeah yeah
yeah yeah i saw them in this intimate
few hundred seats i think it's gonna be
intimate yeah yeah we'll see you we'll
we'll see you as much as you see us you
have to touch us like that yeah we're
gonna make sure that we we meet and
greet every single one of you at the end
of the show guys so
um get your tickets we've given you the
dates multiple times
c tickets.com
looking forward to seeing you guys
love love love gang gang
yo people
while going guys what are you saying you
already know what to do you already know
what to do
pink
pause it right now
this second right now
this second you shouldn't even be
hearing what we're saying right now
because yeah
the thing should be paused and you
should be flying over to the comments
you should hear this little statement
after you've already solved it
and you should be vexed that you
shouldn't have to hear it because you've
already done what you've been asked to
do head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs okay patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs and you
will get over two years
two years
of content from your boys healthy
content healthy content learned content
unwarranted on unfiltered uncensored
ads no nothing over there glorious two
years of it to binge through plus an
episode every single thursday you know
the vibes plus turns out you get early
access to live show tickets now as well
over there i didn't even know that was
going to be an eventuality but now is
this is the case so guys patreon.com is
going to cost you three pound a month
10p a day run the p you know the vibe to
your boys um because we want to live
lavish yes um so guys there's a healthy
community over there head on over to
patreon church sitting in the comments
and uh feel free to message us because
you we message you back first
um on top of that guys if you are
listening to the smooth mellow sensual
tones of your boys j money and fire lord
foreign on spotify or any other audio
platform please for the love of god
leave us a nice review
give us a few stars on the rate and not
asking for five but you know if you want
to give five then please do by all means
but it helps us reach the people we need
to reach
influence indoctrinate i was it in in
indo inaugurate no indoctrinate
i was saying this word the other day
what's this word in doctorate in doc
what's the word i'm looking for brav
when you get people in the car what's it
called man
in
in it's not even in indoctrination
induction
indoctrinated okay cool sorry
raw
wow it's embarrassing yeah i've said
that word a million times yeah yeah yeah
anyway help us indoctrinate peop
indoctrinate
help us get people in the culprit just
bring them in yeah bring a man in and
bring it some people think i can't say
the words that's fine
fart
help us indoctrinate people into the
cult so we can have more white robes
more yeezys more clapping cheeks more
runny jokes a bigger log cabin yeah mom
it doesn't have to be a bunk bed thing
you know it doesn't everyone could have
their own space
but yeah we need the cult to grow so
that when it is time to drink the
kool-aid there's bear man to do it bag
of man yeah yeah yeah replenish it
so guys
um
please leave us a nice review it does
wonders for the show if you are watching
us on youtube please like the video if
you like the video
comment and chirp sitting in there
and uh
two fingers of death ring that
notification bell
so you know when we're posting
because we've post and ghost we haven't
got time to tell the world we post and
we go i like that yeah sometimes i don't
even see when we boast
we've got a new vlog up and coming in
the next couple weeks look out for that
one uh but guys without any further ado
we're heading over to firelord wakes
to um
hit us with some facts
so this actually astonished me when i
read this
um
fun fact of the day guys some of you may
know this some of you like historians
and geography mandem you might know this
but did you know there are only 22
countries that have never been invaded
by britain in the whole world
i didn't know that
but
there was a do you know that proper
geyser-ish comedian
i mean the baggage man there is a bad
man he's older now he doesn't do comedy
anymore he was around when we were
younger he always has american english
english giza e man uh he's got a bald
head
and he always wears like a a jack like a
blazer bill murray not bill murray bill
maher is irish or scottish or something
um bill murray bill maher is an american
actor you already uh are you talking
about billy connolly no no no no no bill
uh bill murray
not bill burr bill murray bill murray is
the guy from space jam
i'm sure he's got a similar name
i'm sure his name is
now i know who you're talking about when
he said boomer i'm sure his name is bone
right
i think i know is it the brother that
used to do the um does he always drink
beer on stage yeah yeah yeah alma is our
marriage i'll marry him yeah something
murray yeah well done we're done we're
done here's our murray yeah he knows his
history
he knows his history does he do a
history thing on dave as well i feel
like he does he might do he was doing a
stand-up one time and he basically
challenged anyone to name a country
that um
britain wouldn't murk in the war
and then any time they'd say a country
he would give them the exact date that
we invaded them and slapped him up wow
wow that was wild off the top of his
head that's that's insane he must be a
history buff he must be and to add to
that there are 196 countries in the
world and only 22 have not been invaded
for context only 22 were not invaded by
britain
jesus
they were some greedy [ __ ]
that's a
they were on some world domination they
were literally on somewhere they really
did that i have to give up they did they
really did they did the damn thing
little island do you think you can name
one country that you think wasn't
invaded by
britain
um are they like developing countries in
there or like they're big boy countries
oh there's a bit of buff
there's definitely a bit above for sure
let me name a country that wasn't
invaded by britain
i'm gonna say
hmm
argentina
nope
brazil
nope
[ __ ] chili
nope
wow
senegal
nope eritrea
nope
russia
nope russia's been smacked up by england
at some point according to this thing
according to this thing um
georgia
nope
[ __ ] uh
czechoslovakia
nope slovenia
nope
give me a continent oh wait oh china
nope
oh no but to be fair i know china has
back in the day yeah
yeah um
there's literally a country from at
least
one continent north korea each continent
sorry
nope
wow um
the philippines
nope
all right just give me one
andorra is the first never heard of it
you've never heard of andorra maybe
belarus okay bolivia
burundi
just the bees we just weren't [ __ ]
with the bees chad congo guatemala ivory
coast
i'm gonna name random ones luxembourg
monaco paraguay sweden
uzbekistan and vatican city there's like
five city makes sense yeah
bro
imagine
i don't know how they missed them once
because looking at africa
domination yeah
probably couldn't be bothered south
america domination america clean out
europe um fam they dominated the world
that's wild they're greedy oh of course
that was when i read i was like
only
22.
the queen has spread her seed boy yeah
fam
we were out here we were out here that's
insane that is insane i can't imagine
being let's say around the times where
bring in my cupboard
safe around the times where um
nigeria unless i was in nigeria when
nigeria got invaded by um the uk or
britain
i don't even know how i would or anyone
would have
lived or like
patterned their day
on the actual day they got invaded
invaded oh yeah
they would have grabbed you by your
nostrils
they would have grabbed you by your
nostrils and draped you on the boat
you're boring mate
get on there you've got shoulders
you've got shoulders and a back on you
get on a [ __ ] boat right for lashes
get on the boat wow
yeah wow yeah man
everywhere ah everywhere did you didn't
even make sense
tiniest little island
it doesn't even make the same thing
because i don't understand how they
overpopulated such large countries
fear
true technology fear yeah yeah they had
all the technology or they would have
had all the yeah they didn't need that
many man there
true couple man here and there what are
you gonna do true
that's nuts man yeah it's nuts oh thank
the lord i was on board in them times oh
same well i couldn't have been born that
would have been i would have been an
abomination
never told the time the history teacher
told me that
i'm sure i've said it on here before
when we were talking about nazi germany
i couldn't have been born
they wouldn't have let me about yeah i
would have been
somewhat i would have been some
plantations owner dirty little secret
yeah facts some plantation owner would
have been his dirty little secret in the
shed facts yeah yeah oh why is he so
cute
like what's going on what's going on
he's just been in the sun
saying folklore yeah so um
what was i gonna say i can't even
remember what i'm saying now
um
[ __ ] what was i even gonna say
your teacher something i was the teacher
mr body was his name buddy mr body
uh scary teacher
but he was a great history teacher okay
but he went round one day
and we were learning about nazi germany
was talking about was like the
annihilation of of the jews and the
blacks and all these people and man
literally was just like oh if it would
have won
and like britain would have lost and all
these other countries would have lost
they would have invaded britain and
there wouldn't have been any black
people and he literally was like you
wouldn't have been here
you wouldn't have been here he was like
james you definitely wouldn't have been
here that's exactly what he said you
wouldn't have been there you wouldn't be
you definitely would have been here
you definitely would have been here
black and white please
please that's laughable
enough
no teacher can say that to children i
don't care what your profession is and i
don't care what laws protect you you
can't say that to children
he wouldn't have got away with it today
he would not got away with it today [ __ ]
fam it was funny you wouldn't have been
here i would have told my mum straight
away yeah mr buddies running around
pointing at you saying they wouldn't
have been if if his boy hitler would
have won
he was top regional would have done a
damn thing we wouldn't have
waste people
he wouldn't waste offspring monkeys how
to read and write if hitler or daddy's
away
[ __ ]
that's so peak but yeah but it was wild
but yeah from that fact is crazy 22
countries only 22 out of 196. that's 174
countries invaded someone hmm this is
the thing as well what happened to stop
them because we're invading the other
22. yeah if i was the king at the time
and someone would have come to me and be
like we've literally
invaded everywhere and i would have been
like right every single country in the
world we've invaded and like oh well
there's 22 that we haven't i would have
been like well so we haven't evolved
yeah we haven't yeah well let's just
finish them off yeah as well yeah
literally there's hardly any left just
do it we can't just not do it it's just
it's incomplete yeah yeah it doesn't
make [ __ ] yeah it must do all of them um
but yeah that's wild and now
here we are
brexit has happened
all the ever-ordered countries want
their independence now yeah yeah yeah
and the queen's just vexed true
true true remember when there was a
little ting going around so that she
died
they got from kovid yeah yeah she was
only the other day that she was seen
after two months yeah
one minute down at m25
sweets me um but anyway that's hilarious
guys um
for a bit of fun today i have done some
some deep diving and i actually have
some icks for us we've not done x in a
minute
in a minute we have not done x
in a while so
for
a good old laugh let's do some x
right bro hear me
i'm gonna get through these i'm gonna
treat you the way you treated me last
week i'm gonna get through these hard
and fast
right
this one tweeted me someone actually
sent me this one directly
a guy sent me this one directly
okay
he had to use oven gloves to take hot
food out of the oven
come on let me breathe come on
the dish is boiling
allow me to just live safely
alive safely this is you this is normal
ppe
standard
this is basic basic
[ __ ] me bro
when he was an emotional when he was
emotional he'd say he was on his myriad
fair enough fam [ __ ] fairy on our
first date
he said don't embarrass me in public
first date
no
i would love to know the context sam wow
don't embarrass me in public wow first
date
we've never met that'll rock me to my
course yeah i think i'm such an invalid
bro on our first date we both ordered
the same soup he asked to try mine
because it looked better
he's a peasant bro he's a [ __ ]
peasant
oh bro this one this one brought me back
to year 7.
wow he used to say tb at the end of
every message
text back
cbx
yes text yes bye i remember that text
back i remember invented that [ __ ] knows
the dumbest [ __ ] tv tv tv if i told her
yeah tb or she didn't tv
yeah you hate me yeah you couldn't face
her the next day yeah yeah
oh bro that's so sweet me his bed didn't
touch any walls it was just in the
middle of the room no
no
[Laughter]
no
no
what he likes to torture people or
something any walls no
no no no
i could never go to a girl's yard and
the bed is just in the middle of the
room
no sweded
from he texted in all caps all the time
for no reason just screaming screaming
that would infuriate me i couldn't live
like that that would be furious i can't
live like that i wouldn't miss sorry i
would never mess with a voice not me i
couldn't live like that fam i told him i
was from lebanon and he said so why are
you on a date with a man
wow
what an idiot wow what an idiot that's a
pilkington tank
that's a carl pilkington tink
[Laughter]
funnier spreader bro oh
fan this one threw me okay
this is worse than the bed okay she
didn't tear the toilet paper at the
dotted line no
no
no
she tears it where she wants
she's a criminal she lives life you're
under arrest so you're a [ __ ]
criminal
what i could never ever ever
go in my bathroom to see my toilet paper
just jagged jagged
nah
no not taunt on the dotted line no
no
no
no
that's insane that that is a lot more
effort bro way more effort oh my god
you're a serial killer oh my god bro ah
he asked for a glass of milk in the
middle of the night
can you imagine i could i genuinely
couldn't fam just lay in there just a
little poke in the back babe milk
he wrote and sang a song for me it
included a wrap first
that little bridge including like rap
first like circa 2001 and then man
wow wow
wow nah nah time on his hands
it included a wrap first i can imagine
ick [ __ ] ick
yuck that's the most disgusting thing
i've ever heard
yuck fam this is during the deed
he slid it in and said
it's so warm
it's so warm in there
he doubled
he doubled down it's so warm
it's so warm in there
man's a virgin
virgin bro wow sweetie me that's all i
have wow tweeted me
top two
not ripping the toilet at the dotted
line and the bed in the middle that's
not touching bearable x that's that's
scary no
that's scary bro
i mix if i would in someone's room to
find their bed just in the middle of the
thing
there's bodies under your floorboards
something is wrong here that's that's
that wow
something's incredibly [ __ ] wrong i
hope she got out safe yeah rags i hope
she got out there's a toilet paper thing
i'll allow it one time i would never
allow it i don't know but i'll give her
the benefit of the doubt if i'm saying
if i went into the first time and saw
that it was jagged i wouldn't assume she
did that on purpose i think something
went wrong something went terribly wrong
okay yeah yeah and i would leave it yeah
a second time get the [ __ ] out yeah
you'll get your [ __ ] you're insane i
would have to say babe sorry
sorry question question
are you are you tearing the toilet paper
like mid
i've tried to mid square
mid panel you're just tearing it she's
like yeah why
yeah
why i just don't like to use the whole
square it's a waste of paper yeah waste
of paper do you not do it on the dotted
line no i just tear i just get exactly
how much i need and i tear it
get your [ __ ] and get the [ __ ] out
because you're insane you're insane and
you're gonna hurt me one day
i don't trust you it's gonna be very
calculated you can't trust someone like
that wow
wow
you literally can't trust them on that
yeah we've completely not done it in a
while that was jokes fam just before we
move on yeah i have my own ick okay well
not my onick
i witnessed someone getting the ick
yesterday um
it was america i think they were married
okay they were like in their 40s okay so
give me let me give you some context let
me drink some water
so i've stumbled across just of these
these things that happened yesterday
i've stumbled across
like a hypothesis
that
i truly believe to to be a functioning
male who can maintain healthy
heterosexual relationships
[Music]
i think you need to be able to
well you need to be confident in that
you can
smack up at least seven out of ten
men who would ever beef you
you need to be able universally you need
to be winning seven at least seven out
of ten fights so let me tell you what
happened
i was at this place here so there's this
uh there's a big like shopping outlet um
near where i live it's called russian
lakes
it's it's big i'm trying to think if
we've been there before
we have been there before do we got food
no to pick up food i remember you we
were there not long ago a few weeks ago
so there fam
on a weekend it's the busiest place
you've ever seen in your life
yeah it's unbearable yeah yeah yeah
because the whole thing only got built
like three four years ago okay it's new
fam is the busiest place you've ever
been to on a weekend i [ __ ] hate it
so i had to go there for this suit [ __ ]
yesterday to sort out this suiting so i
went there to sort out the suit i'm
looking for when i say i'm looking for a
parking space fan
15 20 minutes i'm looking for a parking
space so it's all as to give context you
drive once you're coming in
you drive at the top
lane here and there's aisles of parking
as you go down right
and then if you can't get any parking or
on your way out it loops back round if
you make it all the way down to about it
is background and then you've got the
same chance of course of course parking
on the way back up of course so i've
already done my first loop vex i've gone
all the way around on back up
now as i'm driving i look to my right
and i see at the top end
of this aisle
someone's just got in their car so
clearly so i'm like bet so i swerve into
this lane i'm slowly coming up
and as they're pulling out i see a breda
drive down
he's he's on his first trip in so he's
just made it into the complex i've
already done a lap he's just made it in
so you've got dibs regardless i've got
dibs regardless i've got dibs yeah yeah
fam he sees me see him
i put my foot down but he's way close
he's already a couple he's only a couple
meters away so he zooms so he zooms past
the so that person comes out he zooms
past the space so he can reverse it yeah
fam we get nose to nose bonnet to bonnet
and i said to him i'm after him fam
that's my space that's me that's my
space
that's my space this is me
he's looking at me and i said
huh
i'm going there that's right i'm going
in
[ __ ]
him and his misses are both in the ting
he's like mid-40s he looks like skinny
breath oh
he looks at me yeah he looks at his wife
yeah and he reverses it he doesn't
engage with me he rests into the car
park reverses him to the spot okay
fam
he's
panicked
because he knows he's done wrong yeah
his mrs definitely said [ __ ] him yeah
yeah take the spot yeah yeah yeah we
were here first yeah
so he reversed in from
tried to spin forward tried to reverse
in again nearly smacked the car next to
him slammed on his brakes
it took him three or four tries
on the third try scraped his rims up no
he never and then finally calmed down
pulled out and as he's doing all these
tries i'm looking at his missus the
whole time wow she's disgusting wow
she's
disgusted i can imagine
disgust and they'll make what makes it
worse as as he's going through this
whole pallava the space next to him
becomes available i went straight in
there
as i'm pulling in
you can tell he told his missus get your
[ __ ] and get out
he didn't look at you as i'm pulling in
i'm waiting i'm thinking i beg i get to
chat to this brother
he ran off
he ran off
and you can tell like his wife was like
why is this my life yeah why am i stuck
with this loser oh
i realized
he lives his life he doesn't know he if
he can fight me or not but he is aware
of his
physicality
and his martial arts experience to a
degree that he's not willing to take
that risk
he saw a [ __ ] in the car in front
who made claim to the space yeah he
betrayed him and took the space yeah and
he's not willing to find out what's
going to happen if he has to meet his
homeboy yeah and that if you're not in
that 70 percentile of
seven out of ten i'm confident that
seven out of ten guys that i meet i can
probably knock out
you'll park it perfectly first time
because you're thinking rags if he wants
to be there's no fear yeah he's karma
collected i'm confident i'm gonna back
up with you i've got a 70 chance that
i'm going to get off this car he's going
to do it i'm going to punch him the [ __ ]
yeah and he's going to have to get back
in his car yeah i'm confident in that so
i was as i was watching him panic
and that's the thing as well is that i
was also calm
because i thought
if i do get my hands on this homeboy i'm
going to smack him up yeah
and i'm not even mad yeah yeah and he's
flailing in his car
he's flailing and my reverse parallel
parts and knocks he's bumped up on the
curb nah her head would have rocked she
she wanted a divorce immediately
the fact that when they parked he said
run fam they didn't speak throughout the
whole shopping of course not throughout
the whole shop he was holding her back
they haven't had sex since he was
holding her bag
[ __ ] she's that after that one
altercation she's desperate for a new
man because she realized ma i'm married
to a beta and at some point i'm at at
some level i must have known that
and it that has to be fine also that has
to be fine you have
you have to marry a beta sometimes
because that's just
what's left what's in your lane yeah
because she was butters anyway
no offense to her she was biased she
might have been hot once upon a time
she's not right now
so that's her they're in each other's
lane anyway
neither of them are punching but after
that she thought no
no get me to turkey get me some new tits
give me a new hairline
yeah because this can't run
wow so yeah i made me realize if you're
the kind of guy that
thinks
seven times out of ten
if i have an altercation
i'm gonna get smacked up
maybe i'll win three out of ten fights
but the vast majority those aren't good
odds that's not enough
seven out of ten times
if i get into one of these situations i
need to flee that's not enough can't let
him put his hands on me
that's six out of twenty
nah that's not enough that's not enough
that's what he went through no i saw him
experience that and i saw what it did to
his blood pressure
he must have been
red
or pale one of the two what makes it
worse as well i think he doubled down on
the panic because once i actually got
out the car and started walking towards
the shop i looked back he ran back in
his car and moved his car no he never he
did he moved to another plugins world i
don't know where he moved i didn't stay
to look that long he just got back in
his to be fair he didn't want that
potential altercation of you guys get
back at the same time same time
never oh 100 he would fall to his knees
he'd fall to his face i couldn't have
made eye contact
and he was begging not to see you in the
shopping complex
yeah he got in his whip and he [ __ ]
dipped i don't know if he went home or
if he just moved space probably just
missed space
because he definitely didn't do whatever
errand he came to do
oh
mad so 100 when you got back his car
wasn't there no
i different was it wow yeah
that is embarrassing bless him and bless
her that she had to go through that yeah
bless her cotton socks she didn't need
to witness that yeah i think sorry
if he was on his if he was by himself
and the same altercation happened he
wouldn't tell a soul i would have been
fine with it
what makes it worse if he was by himself
he would have listened to me when i said
yes that's my spot and he would be like
cool sam let me back when i said i'm
parking there yeah he would have been
like i don't want this smoke yeah go for
it yours take yours and it would have
been a blessed altercation because the
space next to him next to you would have
been he would have pulled open for him
and he would have been thinking that's
good karma for the day exactly and i
probably would have spotted him that's i
actually would have been like bro thank
you for that not many people would have
done that you know i rate you if i ever
see you again i'm gonna treat you right
if you ever see yourself in a fight
seven times out of ten i'm gonna back
you
but now now wow you better hope i don't
see you in moss bros
[Music]
you better hope i don't see you trying
on waistcoat oh wow yeah bro it was
tough that's a shame
that's a shame that's mine that's an ick
that's my egg for the day
we've got trash news yes
yes
guys stop what you're doing
sweaty sack summer is approaching and
it's time for you to prioritize the
comfort of your crotch this is big words
coming from big man yeah it's the big
it's the area you need to work on yeah
come on man come on come on comfort of
the quest should be priority one yes sir
that's why the kings of crotch comfort
manscaped have spent two years designing
the most comfortable boxer briefs there
are and guys we can clarify this we've
said it many times advocates we're
advocates you know of the manscape boxer
brief they're smooth sliding they slide
on and they slide off from they slide on
and off but whilst they're on they're
just fitted
yeah they're fitted bruv
um
softest fabric any underwear i've ever
tried okay it's breathable
it's like the gills for your groin come
on come on the gills for your korean
come on they even trademarked the jewel
pouch so you know it's serious
the jewel pouch that's naughty that's
actually naughty the jewel pouch it's
the big package yeah come on
the queen's juice
um so guys i think it's time to invest
in your family jaws so let the bulge
breathe and get 20 percent off plus free
shipping with the code sng sierra
november golf you know come on guys
that's sng at manscape.com
one more time for the people in the back
guys s n g sierra november golf
manscape.com
get
the boxes immediately now all right guys
let's get back to the episode right now
this is a bit of a long one but i'm
gonna give you just cliff notes car
i just can't get into stuff like this
robber who broke into a hair salon is
beaten by a black belt owner and kept as
a sex slave for three days fed only
viagra
for the people
for the people in the [ __ ] bat for
the man in the front read it again for
the man in the front because you need to
be careful
again robber who broke into a hair salon
is beaten by its black belt owner and
kept as a sex slave for three days
fed only viagra
a russian man who tries to rob a hair
salon ended up as a victim when the
female shop owner overpowered him tied
him up naked and then used him as a sex
slave for three days victor 32 admitted
to the police that he had gone to the
salon in russia with intention of
robbing it first of all i'm never
admitting that
never mind that rags but the tables
turned the tables were turned
dramatically when he found himself
overcome by the owner olga 28 who
happened to be a back belt in karate
she allegedly floored the rob the
would-be rubber with a single kick
oh my goodness she allegedly stripped
him naked for the next three days used
him as a sex slave to teach him a lesson
force feed him in viagra to keep force
feeding him viagra to keep the lesson
going
the would-be robber was eventually
released
with the guy saying he had learned his
lesson he went straight to the police
and told him and told them he was in a
back room ordeal
saying that he had been held held
hostage handcuffed naked to the radiator
and fed nothing but viagra
both now have been arrested
when the police
questioned him or questioned her sorry
she said what a bastard yes we had sex a
couple of times but i bought him new
jeans gave him food and even gave him 1
000 rubles when he left
wow
so
he played victor he played fantastic she
didn't feed me in three days just viagra
and just [ __ ] me just banged me she
said no i gave him food i gave him jeans
i gave him this that i gave him some
peas or some chicken change
i could never with bravo imagine curtis
top boy rolling into shelly's shop
i just gave him a kick just a head just
a kick to the chest winded him oh
floored him he woke up just handcuffed
hank off the naked
dick solid solid as a rock
unbeknownst
unbeknown he doesn't understand why just
solid and naked
he's like yeah you're looking she's
tired she's tied him up she's looking
down at him like yeah yeah you wanted to
rob me olga me
bits in our hand bang bang sits on it
you're gonna [ __ ] learn today
and he just nuts and nuts and nuts and
not i'll scream
after the third night i'll scream oh
[ __ ]
after the first one i'll be speechless
after the second one i'll be like
maybe she's just horny yeah she's down
after the third one i'll be screaming
and flailing
you're ripping my wrists or bleeding
let me out three days i wouldn't make it
into mid day two
i'll pray stop
olga stop oh no i wouldn't make it the
first 24. my dick's red i wouldn't make
it the first time before i should be
squeezing my cheeks to pop that back
i'll be swinging my door
get off me black belt that's how you
know you could never know who you can
[ __ ] with like you said three or seven
out of 10 out of 10. someone could just
dappy you yeah there are
there are definitely unforeseen
circumstances where you think you're in
that 70th percentile but you're in that
random hairdresser owner just boots you
in your sternum
and now you're her hoe for three days
[ __ ] i wouldn't make it three days i
wouldn't make it the first twenty four
jack my dick would be so raw
my balls would be aching and the bang to
the chest alone
would would make me see christ
because i would change my ways
femme
i wouldn't believe it
because i i wouldn't believe it because
i'm obviously robbing because i need the
p yeah yeah i'm in this desperate
situation the bang to the chest will
change my life
let alone the sex yeah rags the forced
rape fam the sex will do
their chest thing i think i confirmed
i say she sucker punched me whatever
something happened
i couldn't i'm telling you i couldn't
make it past lunchtime day two i'm
starving i'm thirsty i'm just nutting
nothing now oh and my dick's so sore no
brother i couldn't i couldn't get
knocked out and wake up tied up to a
radio naked rock solid
that image
is scary when you started when you
started the thing yeah i thought it was
a guy that owned the hair salon when i
had sex slave i thought he was getting
banged yeah
but then you said viagra i was thinking
i don't understand i really don't
understand
is the male hairdresser owner a bottom
yes
and needs to feed a viagra so he can get
banged but how's that going to work
yeah it was a chick she top and tailed
him
scary this that's nuts bro you just
never know yeah that's that's real trash
news
that's real trash news
that's terrifying i couldn't believe
that is definitely terrifying definitely
terrifying
worst sex slave thing i've ever i've
ever read yeah man if you've ever read
any more sex life things to be fair
you've got a question for me or a
question for us i've got a question for
i have got a question for us uh i just
need to find it right this also somewhat
ties into
um the trash news that i just said
in a way okay in a way
so she said hey i don't know if you've
seen the question on tick tock but i'm
curious about you guys response
um
it's
what crime would you commit if
committing you will let me read that
again sorry what crime would you commit
if in committing it you make sure no one
can ever commit the crime again
you can only commit one
sorry
you can only commit one
you only get arrested if you get caught
it includes terrorism
murder
rape child molestation etc etc
what are you gonna choose
whoever
thought of that
dark
twisted
i read that i said ra
ra
because it's double jeopardy
oh it's the most double jabbing i've
ever heard double jeopardy
i'm trying to think like
when you say that crime again
it's just that
crime not necessarily that action
so if i shoot someone in the head
no one could commit murder again not
just no one could shoot anyone in their
head again
according to this i hear what you're
saying trying to get the um distinction
all right cool then i'll do child
molestation
yeah i said it
and then i'll murder myself
but i'll do it the most
frigid way
i can do it i don't even know
i don't want an explanation
you don't want an explanation
i don't know i don't know how frigid
would be i think i'm this is hear me out
i'm thinking
i don't even know bro
maybe
someone's at a pool a satin i just run
past
grab pap
on the body pap
the mom's like what the [ __ ]
i did it for you man just a little pink
just a little tap
nothing too serious there won't even
remember it happened
so no child can ever get molested again
all i've got to do is take my bare hand
and touch
a buttock
of a kid
i'll do it
for the betterment of mankind fair
i would easily happily do that for no
child to ever get molested ever again
yeah fair because that's like in my
opinion that is the darkest crime of all
time
i would happily do that
what would you do
i would
[ __ ]
i'm trying to think while the crimes
there are
i've got trash news for you after that
actually okay
i would probably choose if i had to
choose from these let me just choose
from these four
um
[Music]
is racism racism is not a crime is it
i'm gonna say it's a crime yeah kind of
you can get arrested for it so probably
racist some form of racism i don't know
how i'd pattern it but it just seems
like an easy out you know yeah in terms
of like i would i don't know i would
you've done something good for the world
i've done so good it's not it's deep
yeah but
it in context it's not that deep you
know because these are these are mad so
if i roll it up to you into let's say i
take you to
leicester city center
and i'm like say the p word to the top
of your lungs and no one will ever be
racially abused for the rest of time
i mean that's extreme
i mean that's it you gotta make it out
you won't make it out that's it
let's see
[ __ ] that's extreme
that's extreme
um now that's that's also unfair because
you get you got to decide your own in
your life you're into you sorry all
right
who are you gonna pick then you can't be
like a black person you can't pick a
white person i know um i would probably
pick
a
i don't know because i feel like i'm
i'll discriminate one specific race yeah
you're gonna say
now you say
korean
[Laughter]
i've got a smorgasbord of comments for
them
i've got a thesaurus that that man can
have
for the betterment of mankind let's just
say i choose racism all right let's just
say
yeah i would choose racism all right i
don't know what i'll do and how i'd
patent it
but for the betterment of the mankind of
the west of the world like you said i'll
do that
cool
speaking of my one that i picked
have you ever heard of a guy called kane
velasquez cain velasquez no doesn't ring
a bell so ken velasquez is a former ufc
fighter okay
and he's in pen at the minute
check this out he's in pen at the at the
minute because
his
daughter i believe i believe she's like
four or five now yeah
was enrolled in a nursery
and they found out that she
had been um
sexually assaulted by one guy who works
at the nursery
over 100 times
what
over 100 i don't know the details of how
they know it was that many times or
whatever what
he had medited her over 100 times she's
four
or five
so kane velasquez her dad when he found
out so the guy got arrested
he got out of let out on bail
kane
got his gun
got in his car
tracked down homeboy who at the time was
in
um who was it was he was in a car with
his his dad
cain from random off the road
tried to kill him ended up hitting the
dad
now he's in pen
for like attempted murder
um didn't even kill the homeboy
attempted murder homeboy said the actual
child molester is out
on bail kane's
in pen nobel
for doing basically the one thing that
any parent would say they would do if
they found out that their kid had been
um assaulted a hundred times
sometimes the laws of justice are just
insane they're wild aren't they insane
i don't it's i obviously i know they
have like insanity please and stuff
but there needs to be a small little
yeah get out of jail card there has to
be something like that empathy yeah just
like
like the joke
i understand literally i get it everyone
would do it yeah so why are you judging
me for bravo
literally you can't judge me because any
other person would do that
literally anyone would do it well i i
obviously hear that argument but the
fact that the reason why he's in general
because he didn't even shoot the brother
he shot the dad
but even if he did shoot the brother
um
small note as well apparently the dad
because uh was actually the owner of the
nursery so he would have known me yeah
he knew exactly what was oh so [ __ ]
shoot the [ __ ] shoot them all shoot
them all
but yeah regardless of who he hit he
would have gone penn state which country
was this is america jesus this is
america i just don't i honestly don't
understand
what
men or women find attractive about
children obviously it's family it's
psychologically disturbing oh it's it's
done like there's they're just not well
they're literally just not well
there's something wrong with that yeah
that is literally it's a clinical
illness it makes
now it
i've patterned the whole thing it makes
sense now that you said that the pops
owns the nursery because the pop's
clearly molested his own son he must
have done satin along those lines
probably sign along those lines
melissa's own son got his son all
twisted up in the head probably and just
let him around these you let him around
you see we're gonna we're gonna
have a a room full of utes
yeah yeah
yeah disgraceful
wow that's dark very dark isn't it
that's very dark
damn did the pops die
i don't think so that's a shame
that's a huge shame he should have died
he should've
he definitely should have died
i don't think
i genuinely don't think
there's enough rage or anger that will
make me miss my target
i would have to empty the clip and
double check oh
arrest me brother because i'm not
shooting through from cars to the car
yeah i'm running in my throat i'm
getting out of the car and i'm getting
my two kills
bang bang clean shots yeah and then i'll
sit like american history x i'll sit
like this and just wait wait for that
man to come and scoop me up ask me why
say something ask me why
because if i was a police officer and i
came and said what's the [ __ ]
and i've i've been following the case
yeah as soon as i see him how to see the
victims
say less
it makes all the sense just get in the
back and we'll deal with this afterwards
i'm not going to deal with the cuffs
please just get in there just get in the
car that paperwork's going to be
double what it usually is kane do me a
favor get in a [ __ ] car
you take the piss bruh you honestly do
take the piss
[Laughter]
[ __ ] oh
stressful but what a horrible horrible
situation wow so where's his wife is he
does he kane's wife does he have a
missus yeah his wife and kids even the
kids that got moses at 100 times they're
all at yard
chilling
and the kid is still five now you said
i think so and she got molested when
recently up until now up until now
nursery what that's like two three maybe
two in a bit i don't know the story
lines like that g i'm just
i just heard this over 100 that doesn't
make sense
a hundred
that being said i did also hear
apparently statistically
that when um statistically speaking when
a child minister by the time i child
minister is caught they've
already had over a hundred
um encounters
with kids
jesus christ of nazareth i'm so i'm
telling you that's why i touched the
body
that's why i would do it i'd do it for
denman yeah i said i could never happen
again wow
a hundred
how many hundred is i don't have a
hundred friends
do you know what i mean
yeah i know exactly what you mean
wow
it's not fair i just don't i just can't
see how a grown human being can see a
child
and just want to exploit that literally
exploit fam it's wide it's not worth
wasting it calories on it's it's too
dark
it's not worth wasting brain calories
it's not on
it's literally not on thank god you said
brain calories i was thinking why did
you put you mean calories bruv your mind
went west i was like i had to i had to
take a breath i had to take a breath
i had to take a breath because i didn't
know what to laugh at
you know
i said it's not worth the calories
i said what
what
what are you talking about
big big youtube what are you talking
about james i'm sweating
[ __ ]
nah problem of course not that's
disgusting
[Music]
that's funny
oh my abs
oh that's actually funny
yo that's funny bro no my head's
pounding now man that's funny no oh [ __ ]
man that's that's insanity right
[ __ ] hell let's do instagram
questions please let's my [ __ ]
stomach right guys as you know every
week
we ask you
a question on ig and you flood us with
the funniest responses going you guys
are the funniest people on earth and we
love you for that
so
this week we asked most insulting slash
backhanded compliment you've ever
received and as per usu
the responses were juicy
right first one
you're not exactly ugly though are you
wow dread i would date you because
you're pretty but your sister's a bit
skinnier
wow
shank and a twist bruv a lot of these
are shanks and twists of course the
that's that's the definition
i know i know but some of them cut deep
i'm blowing it from a tiny bit sorry
some of them cut deep
you got good wood but you're not my type
that is the definition of a backhanded
compliment because i feel great about it
but [ __ ] you
but use me yeah [ __ ] you i will be back
tomorrow but i hate you
i'll be back tomorrow
you'd be perfect if you weren't so tall
she's five foot ten
yikes
you're well spoken for an ethnic person
wow
you're so cute i definitely sit down to
kiss you
that's like year eight vibes
wow that's the definition of cute
you're so pretty but why'd you wear
glasses that's like wearing makeup and
then covering yourself with dirt
i need to see
i literally need vision
wow
[Laughter]
you look better tanned because you don't
look ill anymore
your body brings up your rating
yeah fair play
you're really good looking in the dark
you know
jesus
my ex once said to me
you're pretty for a moderately ugly
girl fam that's
that's categories
that's categories i smacked you because
i loved you
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] he told me he liked me and said
you're perfect because i actually
watched bbw porn anyway
on some drake thing wow
you're good looking enough to meet my
friends but you're ugly enough enough
for them not to want you
you're just smacked by you know he said
that's a win
win
wow
from multiple people you look so much
better in person so my fire selfies
ain't so fire fam
wow
this one wow you bought all that i could
never well sorry let me start again wow
you bought all that
i could never my men love to spoil me
but that's good for you though
that's a friend to that's a frantic
that's a galactic outing my man my men
love to spoil my men love to spoil me
but that's good for you though that's
good that you can afford that
because no one's spoiling you
i know why you wear such bright swimwear
to get the attention off your face
you smell so good
i thought you were going to smile
god
i couldn't even oh my god
the funny thing is you have you
literally have no idea what i'm gonna
say i have no idea
and you would never be able to guess
james all right okay okay i'm ready i'm
ready i'm ready i already know my back's
gonna hurt after this
you smell so good
i thought you were gonna smell oh don't
you
oh the [ __ ] on
oh [ __ ]
all right last time i'm all right cool
go go who's gonna say it you got this
bro
you smell so good
i thought you were gonna smell like
fried rice or cat
what's racist
[Laughter]
oh bro
[ __ ] i knew my back was gonna hurt after
that
fried rice or cats
wow
oh [ __ ]
how did youtube manage to produce
something so cute i would never know
dread peak
time you're sweating white
wipe you're glittening i have to
sorry guys interlude interlude [ __ ] me
[ __ ] hell i'm telling you that fry
wrestling took me i could see it it took
me james
sex with my ex was wild and loads but
with you it's nice and not too often
the a-okay
my guy friend said to me
you could totally get with my boy he's
mad desperate these days
dread
big dicks can hurt yours is perfect
because it doesn't hurt at all
this one
i i know they [ __ ] after this one i
don't know why i just know all right so
when i read this it reminded me of that
rihanna
um meme where she i think she sat on a
chair she like winks at you i think
you've seen it before all right say ls
he said to her the best and worst thing
about you is that mouth
[Laughter]
they [ __ ] after that
[ __ ]
yeah yeah
[ __ ] i don't know jesus yeah yeah yeah
you see what i'm saying
you see you have to run at you i have to
run that out
yeah ah
i want your confidence i don't know how
you look i don't know how you feel good
looking the way you do
what
that's a woman
i know you don't know it is
i go out with ugly girls like you
because you're grateful and you won't
cheat
[ __ ] bro
i hate you but i love [ __ ] that kitty
cat
raunch that is wrong that's raunch
you have beautiful teeth do they also
come in white
[Laughter]
that's funny you've got the body of a
goddess but the hands of a hobbit
you're not gorgeous gorgeous but there's
something about you oh dear
some guy some guy on
some guy on muzz match asked me to be
his second wife he didn't even have a
first one yet
she said he said no matter what you're
my backup
you're not first wife material
wow he didn't even have a first one you
wouldn't have a first if you didn't
forget your hairline in the womb you'd
be a 10 out of 10. i've been wearing
hats ever since
the audacity that will rock anyone's
confidence no rags your hair is so
gorgeous is it natural or is that fake
too
i accidentally called my girlfriend
hedge she stopped cooking my dinner
immediately
[Music]
mid fry
that's funny if i had a sister i want
her to date you so we could be like
family
wow
me
getting a haircut tomorrow gonna go from
a six to a her a six with a haircut
no
the cutthroat
fight me i love hanging out with you
just not in public
[ __ ] i love your eyebrows especially the
left one
do you know how
cruddy that sam
you can't say that to a girl you could
you can't say that to a human being
especially the left one
no fight talk nah
because what you're saying is that i'm
not symmetrical yeah yeah
that's what you're saying you're saying
i'm asymmetrical
and it's not on
[ __ ] imagine james this one is peak
go your ass makes up for the year seven
boys changing ring chest that you've got
the year seven boys changing room chest
that you've got nah that's a tongue
twister
that's a you can't sleep me on a tongue
twisting thing because i can't even
repeat it back to you i'm like
year seven changing room boys chest
oh wow
that's just nipple that literally is
skin and nipple wow
i was dancing and my mom's friends said
i finally see why men find you
attractive
dread that is [ __ ] dread you look
great have you stopped eating again or
what because i know you're not working
out
[ __ ]
me
i feel fat today him
you were fat when i met you
that's the backhanded compliment wow
i like your yellow teeth because it
tells me you're living like flight
there's no tomorrow
that's not
after laying down some crazy dick she
said
i should let fat guys [ __ ] me more often
a woman will literally say anything
anything she wants they do
anything they want they don't even
that's not a backhanded compliment they
don't care about repercussions it's just
a statement yeah you're fat and it's
true
you're fat and you did good job i'm just
staying i'm complimenting you it's not
backhanded it's a compliment yeah i'm
letting you know something you already
know also something you didn't know your
dick is good you already knew you were
fat so why are you crying [ __ ] you know
my mum introduced me to her friends and
said be careful she spits when she talks
[Laughter]
[ __ ] sake you're not dumb you just
don't have any common sense oh i know
better than people to be fair this is
the last one
you're pretty for a lesbian i slapped
him across the face
oh my thanks bro yo
like i said you man you guys are the
funniest guys on the planet man general
public too funny that was too funny that
was good
right guys
that's another one bites the dust um
look out as we said before this thursday
tickets go live on patreon for our live
show they do this friday tickers are
available for the general public
so guys we hope to see you there yeah
ma'am um please
just give us the clout yeah sell us out
in like 10 minutes sell us out in 10
minutes we we need to run it up yeah we
need that we need your money we need
that ego boost yeah but anyway guys as
always thank you so much we'll see you
on thursday love love going on
[Music]